hey guys just a quick little information
update we just got done with our ALS
charity livestream for August and I
wanted to say thank you to everyone who
came out it was our most successful yet
we peaked at about 42,000 people in the
stream which is more than we've ever had
by a huge margin and I know that we
smashed a record for how much money has
been raised for charity because we sold
four thousand nine hundred tiny box Tim
plushies we completely sold out we only
had a limited quantity and we sold two
thousand two hundred and thirty tiny box
Tim t-shirts I believe and that's just
going to put an incredible money towards
research towards ALS and we talked about
it on livestream about what ALS really
is because a lot of people have heard
the name now because of all the ice
bucket challenge videos but not many
people looked into the reality of what
it's like to live with the disease or
have family members that go through it
it's truly horrifying because it's a
neuron degenerative disease it makes it
so that you can't use your muscles
anymore and it's so important that we
get some sort of treatment or cure for
the disease as soon as possible because
it's just that bad it may not affect as
many people as other disease but man it
is terrifying to go through and some of
the emotional videos that I've seen
online are just they're heart-wrenching
to see so thank you everyone who took up
the cause and a big thank you to Bob and
Wade for flying out here I mean it's
hard going anywhere for just a day to
fly in and fly out right away so thank
you you guys for doing that for this
charity livestream it made it the most
fun we've ever had in and I think the
most successful by far so sincerely from
the bottom of my heart thank you guys
for being such good friends and it was
good to hang out with you guys again
even though we were only able to get
dinner and then he immediately had to go
but still it was good to see you guys
again and just thank you everyone in
general who I haven't thanked already
even though I've been thanking everybody
in turn this was awesome and I know that
we're gonna do it again in the future
real soon every month that's my promise
and at the end of this week I will be
going to PAX Prime in Seattle I will be
there pretty much the whole time and I
believe that I will be on a few panels
even my
maybe I don't know anything certain yet
people have been very wishy-washy was
the information for me but I will be
there and I will be so happy to meet you
guys who is going I may not be able to
do a meet up outside of pax because I
don't have a lot of time I'm very busy
when I'm there but if you see me
anywhere on the street in the convention
anywhere at all
say hi to me come up and say hi to me it
doesn't matter how busy I look I am very
happy to meet you guys I'm always
excited to hear the stories that you
guys have to tell so please don't
hesitate to come up to me and other than
that just that's pretty much all that's
going on this is just a quick little
vlog even though quick by my definition
is not that quick in general but just
thank you guys again for doing
everything that you've done to support
me and support the causes that I believe
in it's just really going to be exciting
going into the future with all the new
things that I have planned and the new
resources that I have planned and so
many new subscribers coming in after
3,000,000 happened just last week we're
already at 3 million 150,000 something
it's astonishing just thank you guys so
much for thinking that I'm worthy of
your time
and that's pretty much all I gotta say
I'm about to start blathering again but
that's really all I gotta say
so thank you guys and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye